[Music]
originally a quiet place 2 was supposed
to be released in mid-march 2020 but due
to the pandemic
it had to be postponed now the sequel
has started in theaters in some parts of
the world and unsurprisingly has been a
complete success
this is a good time for paramount to
announce the debut of this still
untitled spin-off of the series the idea
originates from john krasinski although
he himself has delegated the directing
of the spin-off to his colleague jeff
nichols there is speculation that the
spin-off will say goodbye to the abbott
family in order to introduce new main
characters to an earth overrun with
sound sensitive monsters niggles should
have no problems meeting the high
expectations of fans and critics
after all the 42 year old had his big
breakthrough in 2012 with the
apocalyptic drama take shelter
hopefully the spin-off will live up to
the franchise and we're looking forward
to the release on march 31st 2023
until then we can obviously recommend a
quiet place part 2
which has already hit u.s cinemas after
we reported a lot about spider-man no
way home in the past few weeks we are
even more pleased to share news about
spider-man
into the spider-verse 2 with you as
reported by the hollywood reporter
insecure creator
issa rey has been cast in the role of
spider-woman the multiverse speculator
has so far received personal support
from shamiq moore
and haley steinfeld who will voice the
characters miles morales and spider-gwen
so the third in the bunch is now rey in
her role as jessica drew alias
spider-woman
she has been known in the comics since
1977 and is thus one of the better known
characters in the universe and by the
way there are three directors that work
behind the camera
joaquin dos santos camp powers and
justin k thompson
they will direct the script by david
callahan the responsible parties are
still maintaining a low profile in terms
of content which is why we are looking
forward to further news on the animated
sequel
spider-man into the spider-verse 2 is
scheduled for release on october 7th
2022 supernatural star
jason eccles posted a very bearded
picture of himself a few weeks ago
giving fans a first glimpse of his new
role as soldier boy
as we reported back then his appearance
differs significantly from the comic
book original where soldier boss
exterior is definitely not characterized
by big beard
besides in the comics by garth anders
and derek robertson there are two
soldier boys one from world war
ii and one from the present in season
three both are supposed to be brought
together and become one by actor jensen
echols
which is a possible reason for the new
look of the superhero anyway
the focus of the new season is on the
u.s american history of the superheroes
which were rather neglected than the
previous two seasons
and two fantasy new images we see
soldier boy in a military green outfit
and his striking shield
which shows certain parallels to captain
america and not without reason
the history is not dissimilar either
with soldier boy being the very first
superhero of
the boys universe fighting for his
country back in world war ii
and find an appeal and use pop culture
while has not been officially confirmed
yet we assume that echo's character will
be appearing in the present of the boys
and not in the past
one side of this the visual discrepancy
between the officially released outfit
photos and his instagram channel
where he likes to present himself with a
full beard and waits in preparation for
his role
while the former might show the soldier
boy from world war ii echols beard look
will most likely show the soldier boy of
the present day
we're definitely looking forward to the
boys season 3 which may be released
exclusively on amazon prime as
early as mid-2022
the sequel to the extremely popular
shazam won't be released until 2023
but there's already a first short teaser
for the dc adventure
it shows the eponymous main character
zachary levi in a new outfit
what's new about it is the significantly
smaller lighting bolt on its chest as
well as the much sleeker design of the
suit a clear improvement in our eyes
of course the question arises as to why
the superhero who's actually just a
super power billy batson
has been given a new look many are also
surprised that shazam doesn't seem to be
wearing his cape anymore
which either means that he has taken it
off or that it will be inserted via cgi
in post-production
director david f sandberg had no precise
answer either
he simply posted that the rather early
shooting is already in progress
perhaps however this is simply a
reaction to the many critics of the
original suit who felt the design was
trashy as well as puffy in their eyes
another glimpse can be found on the page
just jared which actually has their
first
unofficial set photos of the superhero
upbeat sleeve we appreciate the early
start of filming and look forward to the
release on june 2nd
2023
the sequel to avatar is scheduled to
officially hit theaters at the end of
2022.
just in time for world oceans day
producer john landau once again posted
new footage via twitter this time
in the form of concept art it hardly
could have been any more appropriate
since the focus of avatar 2 is on the
beautiful and the waterworld of pandora
the fluorescent blue image proves that
the seas of the moon which is located in
the alpha centauri solar system
don't have to hide from the already
known flora not only do you see the
diversity of species but above all you
can see a new
plesiosaur-like sea creature next to all
the corals and underwater plants it's a
really atmospheric picture
in fact it's a pity that is not a real
clip from the movie we're looking
forward to seeing more impressions from
pandora and are excited about the
release date on december 16th
2022 it has been clear for some time
that narco star
tanaka weather will play the villain in
the upcoming black panther too
this side illumi nerdy now believes to
have found out that the 40 year old will
not embody just
any antagonist rather he will portray
none
other than neymar the submariner neymar
who is more or less the mcu equivalent
of dc's aquaman
has been around even longer than his
counterpart and has been part of marvel
comics since 1939.
character-wise he's rather cleric and
impulsive mainly because he's on a
vendetta against the country dwellers
who destroyed his beloved underwater
home
naturally he's able to breathe
underwater without any difficulty
and he's superior to any normal mortal
in terms of strength
speed and endurance as if that weren't
enough
the son of an atlantean mother and the
human father is capable of flying when
he's not
diving in the marvel universe the
hostility between wakandans and
atlanteans would definitely match
not least because of numerous illusions
such as an avengers end game where koyu
refers to a devastating seaquake
if the website illuminati is to be
believed neymar's cousin companion
nomoria and the warlord etumo will
also play a part we will know more about
the release of black panther 2
wakanda forever on july 8th 2022 at the
latest
what do you guys think are illuminati's
theories convincing or do you believe
that huerta might play a totally
different villain altogether
feel free to let us know your opinion in
the comments
the not entirely uncontroversial
borderlands movie adaption is slowly
taking shape
on twitter those responsible have now
posted their first group picture of this
sci-fi action film
sadly you can only see the silhouettes
of the stars against the bright
background
though they already give quite a bit
away you get to see lilith the red
haired leader of the exterminator team
she is embodied by kate blanchett and
belongs to the group of sirens who are
characterized above all by their
fearlessness
and their unpredictable temper roland
played by kevin hart
is also among the characters he in turn
is especially adept in the field of
technology and frequently the last
resort of his team
hollywood legend jamie lee curtis plays
the intelligent scientist patricia
tannis who probably meets
all the requirements of a mad genius and
also knows much about the secret chamber
the 13 year old ariana greenblatt who
already appeared in
avengers infinity war stars as the
character tiny tina the orphan's great
likings are explosions and tea parties
she is protected by her not quite as
intelligent but all the stronger
bodyguard creek
the latter is played by german romanian
actor floriano monteanu who is in no way
inferior to his prodigy when it comes to
brute force
last in the lineup is of course jack
black's character is cl for ptp
the robot who is not noticeably inferior
physically is happy to let others take
the lead in conflict and has a very
wicked tongue considering his lack of
strength so he's quite the perfect
sidekick for the crew also confirmed to
appear
edgar ramirez as atlas oliver richters
as chrome janina gavin carr
as knox and haley bannon in a role yet
to be revealed
the action-packed video game adaption by
hostile director eli roth will be
released next year at the earliest
unfortunately an official release date
has not yet
been announced the official figures for
disney's cruella speak volumes
as a disney representative confirmed a
few days ago the box office sales are
very satisfactory not least because of
the above average reviews on the
relevant portals
no surprise then that work is already
underway on a sequel to the live action
remake it is still unclear as to when
the sequel will be released but it is
highly likely that director craig
gillespie and screenwriter tony mcnamara
will be back in action
a return on mama stone in front of the
camera as the main character trailer
devil is
also considered extremely likely
although nothing has been officially
confirmed yet as always
we will keep you up to date on further
news above the live action sequel
[Music]